dans combien de temps vous étiez
ensemble on était ensemble
[Musique]
disons que notre histoire a commencé en
2017 et ensuite après tout se
complexifier parce que moi je suis un
homme marié et pas d'accord
ensuite ensemble officiellement en fait
bah non parce qu'en plus moi si j'avais
dû être avec Margot j'aurais fait les
choses quand même ensuite dans l'ordre
sur moi j'ai failli au départ mais tu
ailles tout quitter pour Margot
je me suis posé la question en fait
c'était tout le temps des disputes des
disputes des disputes et d'un côté je
comprenais pas ce que pour elle était
numéro 2 entre guillemets mais je
[Musique]
t'ai toujours obligé de la contenir
d'essayer de la de la raisonner et puis
ça c'est super c'est super dur donc
sur le point de vue de la relation j'ai
aussi j'ai mes torts dans les dans les
agissements de la façon de faire
mais je pensais pas qu'un jour il y
aurait de durée de la violence
psychologique et tout
et des menaces qu'elle m'a fait qu'elle
m'a suivi en voiture qu'elle et qu'elle
appelle ma femme sur le lieu du travail
qui lance des cailloux sur ma fenêtre
quelle qu'elle me dise qu'elle me dise
l'adresse de la nouvelle adresse de ma
femme sans faire de phrases voilà j'ai
pour moi tout ça j'ai dit je te
comprends pas en fait je te comprends
pas je sais pas pourquoi tu me fais ça
ça a été beaucoup à la base de 7 à la
base non c'est elle qui a mis ou quoi
votre femme là vous partez en Israël
sont tout seul tout seul tout seul parce
que je disais c'est une histoire qu'on
vous êtes célibataire maintenant vous
avez tous
le divorce divorce soit prononcé voilà
mais moi j'ai c'est ce que je lui ai dit
à moi avant moi j'ai besoin de prendre
du recul surtout j'ai besoin de faire
cette nouvelle aventure et je vous
garantis qu'à partir du moment où je où
j' ai dit que que j'ai accepté ce poste
en Israël à partir de ce moment-là j'ai
plus heureux dormir comme un bébé
j'étais super bien mais je m'ennuie des
critiques à cause de ça juste parce que
j'étais bien. À ce qu'il paraît tu étais
lumineux te pétillant ça y est tu pars
tu me laisser tes tes pétillant et après
tu m'abandonnes après après on peut la
comprendre aussi moi ça
franchement
pourquoi
très très violente suite à une dispute
parce que vous avez dit quelque chose à
la provoquer elle est piquée j'en sais
rien et ça j'ai pas j'ai pas d'unité
vous êtes quand même beaucoup plus fort
qu'elle même si elle est en furie
pourquoi vous l'immobiliser pas pourquoi
c'est compliqué pour
moi
[Musique]